avec valérie pécresse nous reprendrons
en main notre politique énergétique
parce que c'est un enjeu de souveraineté
d'emploi et de pouvoir d'achat nous
supprimerons la tva sur les taxes sur
l'électricité la taxe sur la taxe ça
suffit nous indique seront les frais
kilométriques sur les prix des
carburants en supprimant le plafond des
40 km nous rendrons au français la
totalité des taxes sur les carburants
collectés en raison de la hausse des
prix soit 25 centimes par litre nous
ferons une relance gaullienne du
nucléaire pour garantir aux français une
électricité décarbonés et à petit prix
nous dissocier rond la fixation du prix
de notre électricité du marché européen
qui est lui-même indexé sur le gaz nous
referons du nucléaire un fleuron
industriel
nous reviendrons immédiatement sur la
décision irresponsable des manuels
m'apprend de fermer certaines de nos
centrales nous construirons ciseaux p r
dont 4 d'ici 2035 et nous soutiendrons
les petits réacteur modulaire nous
relancerons le programme astrid qui
permet de préparer le réacteur de
quatrième génération nous n'opposons pas
le nucléaire aux énergies renouvelables
qui sont un complément de production
indispensable
aucun projet éolien ne pourra sortir de
terre sans l'accord des populations
locales nous soutiendrons tous les
dispositifs de production d'énergie
renouvelable
nous développerons les biocarburants le
biogaz et l'hydroélectricité avec un
important effort de modernisation
faire la chasse ou gay sq nous réduirons
les prix de l'électricité pour les
français qui réduisent leur consommation
lors des pics doubleront le rythme
actuel de rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments publics et des logements en
lançant un grand plan de rénovation du
parc social nous lancerons un plan de
lutte contre les fuites de gaz méthane
très agressif plc
[Musique]